[Música]
tres mujeres jóvenes en el cine en
cualquier otro lugar del mundo esta
escena no tendría nada de extraño pero
estamos en Arabia Saudita las salas de
cine fueron reabiertas hace pocos años
antes estas Jóvenes sólo iban a centros
comerciales divertirse por la noche era
algo impensable para las mujeres
solteras hoy safiya rim y salwa celebran
una gran primera vez
antes todos teníamos miedo pensábamos
hay un chico no puedo ir pero ahora todo
va bien Podemos hablar libremente sí las
mujeres están más cómodas son más libres
incluso siendo pequeñas cosas cotidianas
está muy bien el cine es un primer paso
estamos dando pequeños pasos la sociedad
se va abriendo poco a poco
al igual que otras personas en la sala
utilizan sus teléfonos todo el tiempo
Aunque Arabia Saudita es un país
hiperconectado solo ahora está
descubriendo la gran pantalla
sí estoy en redes como todos Es la
primera vez que voy al cine tengo muchas
ganas de que empiece
es el fin de una prohibición única en el
mundo que llevaba 35 años en vigor en
esta rígida monarquía la decisión fue
tomada por un hombre
mohamedman príncipe heredero de Arabia
Saudita un gesto de apertura al mundo de
la parte de un dictador decidido a
aplicarle una terapia de choque a su
país
[Aplausos]
Pero también es una forma de sacar a
Arabia Saudita de su dependencia del
petróleo tan solo el cine debería
generar más de 20.000 millones de euros
de aquí a 2030 y fomentar el turismo en
un país que hasta ahora estaba
completamente cerrado
cuando uno ve una película en la que hay
un paisaje muy bonito una ciudad que le
dan ganas de hacer conocerlos el
objetivo es limpiar la imagen del país
hacer olvidar que aquí Los Defensores de
los derechos humanos y los periodistas
son perseguidos encarcelados o
asesinados un país donde fuimos
escoltados por empleados del Ministerio
de medios de comunicación durante todo
nuestro rodaje donde la libertad de
expresión el derecho a manifestarse o a
criticar a la monarquía no existen
esta operación de propaganda recae sobre
los hombros de un monarca todopoderoso
que mediante la intimidación acabó
concentrando todos los poderes llegó y
dijo Ahora soy yo el líder
Y actualmente Toma las decisiones solo
[Música]
vamos a una cita en lleida con nuestros
acompañantes
Esta es la ciudad más cosmopolita del
reino a orillas del mar rojo
puerta de entrada de los peregrinos de
todo el mundo que se dirigen a los
lugares Santos de Medina y la Meca
[Música]
en este café al estilo occidental un
equipo está instalando decorados e
iluminación
estamos en el set de rodaje de una
película
una producción Saudita escrita por
Fátima albanahui
[Música]
una exitosa actriz y por primera vez en
su carrera directora de un largometraje
Hacemos todos los planos para esta
secuencia luego necesitamos el plano 61
el que habla del pasado hacemos un plano
de talla del padre que mira su cuchillo
creo que es lo mejor y luego filmamos el
plano 62
Ok hagamos el encuadre veamos dónde se
sientan exactamente y luego empezamos
vale vamos todos veamos cómo sale
[Música]
Si hubiera tenido que hacer esta
película hace 5 años habría sido difícil
muy difícil pero ahora lo que quiero es
sentirme lista lista para disfrutar de
esta nueva libertad
es parte de la juventud dorada
licenciada en psicología de Harvard es
una Saudita activa para quien dirigir un
equipo no es una tarea difícil
no se ve lo más importante es que la
persona que se siente ahí haga algo que
tome té o algo ok
en el set los idiomas y las
nacionalidades se mezclan
los actores son sauditas el director de
fotografía es búlgaro
la mayoría de los técnicos son libaneses
o egipcios
[Música]
también le decimos la hormiga Aunque no
es una hormiga hace demasiado ruido para
hacerlo
este es nuestro actor principal que
interpreta a mi padre
y aquí tenemos a la mejor tercera
asistente de dirección del mundo es una
tiktoker genial muy natural
su película está basada en su vida
una expatriada Saudita que regresa a un
país en pleno cambio y encuentra a su
padre que tiene una enfermedad mental en
medio de la crisis del covid
[Aplausos]
pero no esperen una crítica al sistema
Saudita que se ponga en tela de juicio
la monarquía en ningún mensaje
abiertamente feminista
todo lo que hago es política como hablo
con la gente como comunico como susurro
al oído de alguien en lugar de hablarle
delante de todo el mundo
eso es política Así que en vez de ser
moralista de hablar Prefiero ser un
ejemplo que los demás puedan aprender de
mí
la presencia de Fátima albanahui en el
set es un cambio considerable en un país
donde hasta hace cinco años la presencia
de las mujeres solo era tolerada en el
espacio público Incluso hoy sus vidas
están sometidas a la tutela de un hombre
todo ha cambiado es un giro de 180
grados tengo hijas y me alegro mucho por
ellas las oportunidades vienen de todas
partes de repente las puertas se abren y
aparecen muchos talentos que antes no
veíamos
los hombres y mujeres son iguales ambos
sexos pueden expresarse crear tener
historias que contar y yo estoy
encantado de ser parte de la aventura
[Música]
para el cine Saudita Este es un
Renacimiento tras una larga interrupción
forzada en los años 50 en las
principales ciudades del reino se
organizaban proyecciones de películas
producidas por compañías petroleras
estadounidenses le pedimos a uno de Los
Pioneros del Séptimo arte Saudita que
nos remontara en el tiempo sale fouzdan
empezó su vida en el cine alquilando
videocitas recuerda las películas de su
infancia proyectadas en público como
aquí en la vieja hiedra
[Música]
el cine se organizaba en casa las
mujeres se sentaban atrás y los niños
adelante las proyecciones se hacían en
la casa del vecino todo se reunían para
ver la película a menudo lo hacíamos
para una gran ocasión como he leído los
fines de semana el jueves o el viernes
por la noche no era muy caro reuníamos
dinero entre nosotros o si alguien tenía
dinero suficiente para alquilar el
proyector y la película La veíamos en su
casa
pero todo se detuvo en 1979 muy
indignados por lo que calificaban como
la actitud de la moral en el reino y la
corrupción del régimen
200 fundamentalistas irrumpieron en la
gran mezquita de la
mecao
el asedio duró casi dos semanas y dejó
cientos de víctimas
o niño obtuve de motivación
El incidente marcó profundamente a la
familia real
[Música]
en contestación fue una disputa
religiosa con ultraconservadores aún más
conservadores que ellos que les decían a
los Saúl ustedes son malos musulmanes
nosotros demostramos que somos buenos
musulmanes entonces cerraron anularon
todos los signos de apertura cine teatro
literatura y cierta libertad religiosa
[Música]
Fue entonces que sale decidió irse de
Arabia Saudita
se fue a vivir a Egipto y luego al
Líbano regresó a su país en contadas
ocasiones
vengo de una familia muy devota y para
ellos mi vinculación con la Industria
del cine y el video era un pecado
las tensiones religiosas son un tema
delicado en Arabia Saudita y aquí
siempre nos están escuchando
de hecho había dos bandos Opuestos el
gobierno que autorizaba el cine y los
religiosos que lo consideraban un pecado
yo no soy religioso soy liberal y
la gente del ministerio nos interrumpe y
le indica a nuestro interlocutor que es
mejor no hablar de este doloroso pasado
la entrevista termina aquí pero a pesar
de todo sale fauzan va a presentarnos a
alguien muy cerca de ahí se encuentra
una universidad muy nueva que recibe a
unos 10.000 estudiantes y es dirigida
por el doctor shehapson
mire esto doctor mire lo que hizo por
nosotros Dios lo bendiga Es todo gracias
a sus esfuerzos doctor
fue el primer Saudita que estudió cine
en Hollywood fue compañero de clase de
George Lucas
estudié en una de las universidades más
importantes de California donde
estudiaron los más grandes productores y
directores
pero cuando volví a casa era imposible
trabajar en la industria del cine Así
que empecé a estudiar televisión
esta universidad es un orgullo en estos
estudios que cuentan con equipos de
Última Generación estudia la promoción
2023 de la escuela de cine
grabando acción
puedes presentarte soy naguaf Mohamed
pagabas qué te animo a inscribirte en
nuestra escuela
primero había oído hablar mucho de esta
escuela y las personas que conozco que
se han graduado de acá ahora tienen
buenos trabajos
yo me enamoré de la dirección de cine
de verdad quiero hacer películas si Dios
quiere
querido amigo te imaginas lo que esto
nos hace sentir
trabajamos en la industria
cinematográfica desde los años 60 el
doctor y yo hemos estado en Egipto
Europa Marruecos túnez
y ahora vemos esto y es nuestro sueño
hecho realidad ves
para esta nueva generación internet fue
durante mucho tiempo su única ventana al
mundo
los sauditas se apropiaron de este medio
de expresión están en YouTube y en las
redes sociales a pesar de la censura
[Música]
Este vídeo satírico es del año 2013
tiene 17 millones de reproducciones
[Música]
desde la prohibición a los cines en 1980
se han rodado algunos largometrajes en
el país en su paso por Kan en 2013 la
directora Saudita haifa alman Sur
explicó que tuvo que rodar escondiéndose
de la policía de la moral y hablar con
sus equipos por walkie talkie
en el país los sexos están separados Así
que tenía que Quedarme en una Van Es lo
normal la gente no espera Ver mujeres
trabajando en la calle
su película el sueño de estrenada en
Venecia cuenta la historia de una joven
que se enfrenta a las estrictas normas
de una sociedad en la que las mujeres
viven encerradas
[Música]
de repente en 2018 el país se abre
acceso al estadio para las mujeres
espectáculos conciertos
[Música]
el príncipe heredero Mohamed Bin salman
tenía 32 años en aquel entonces y él
mismo hacía parte de Esta generación
ávida de nuevas experiencias
pero su movida también era política vio
como las primaveras árabes de los países
vecinos Egipto y túnez empujaron al
exilio a antiguos dirigentes
[Música]
rápidamente entendió que su rígido país
necesitaba un respiro
[Música]
selecciona
es la juventud más conectada del mundo
con el mayor número de cuentas de
Facebook o YouTube por habitante y
también es la juventud con la mayor tasa
de obesidad del mundo es como si la
juventud estuviera conectada al mundo y
encerrada en casa es un gran riesgo
político y el príncipe supera este
riesgo diciéndoles a los jóvenes estoy
de su lado estoy del lado de la apertura
estoy del lado del Progreso
lo que el príncipe está haciendo en
Arabia es muy inteligente porque les
está ofreciendo una ventana para
respirar que no es política que no los
empujaría a una movilización política
[Música]
pero esta nueva Arabia Saudita también
tiene otra cara mucho menos amable
el príncipe comienza reprimiendo
severamente a quienes se oponen a su
política
primero a los religiosos conservadores
no duda en encarcelar a quienes rechazan
la apertura de la sociedad
luego arremete contra sus oponentes como
llama al Yogui periodista exiliado y
crítico del régimen se está volviendo en
una dictadura de un solo hombre
toma el control de todo crea un ambiente
de intimidación y miedo
los sauditas están siendo silenciados
las cosas no son transparentes y esta no
es una buena forma de reformar el país
tiene que hacer algo
la última imagen decayogi dio la vuelta
al mundo en el consulado Saudita en
Estambul fue torturado asesinado y luego
desmembrado por agentes del príncipe
linaal vive en Bruselas es una activista
Saudita defensora de los Derechos
Humanos aquí puede desplazarse Sin temor
a ser detenida o interrogada por las
autoridades
en su país decenas de activistas por los
derechos de las mujeres han sido
encarceladas
su propia hermana luzna se grabó
conduciendo un automóvil cuando las
mujeres aún tenían prohibido hacerlo en
mayo de 2018
[Música]
en la cárcel fue torturada antes de ser
puesta en libertad sin poder salir del
país
hoy el régimen permite por fin que las
mujeres conduzcan
pero la represión continua
lo nuevo ahora es que incluso personas
que no son conocidas que no tienen peso
que nadie conoce
también están siendo arrestadas
encarceladas durante décadas en prisión
Este es el caso por ejemplo de una mujer
llamada Salma hejab que fue condenada a
34 años de prisión
por tuitear un tweet mío en el que
hablaba de mi hermana
Así que hablar de mi hermana es un
delito en Sí ahora
no es una excepción tenemos a nuk
alkatani que fue condenado a 45 años por
sus tweets
desde la capital belga lineal jaslul
puede ver las últimas creaciones del
cine Saudita pero sabe que esta apertura
es una maniobra para darle al régimen
una imagen moderna y respetable
lamenta el silencio de artistas y
directores a pesar de que ahora tienen
una audiencia global
[Música]
no voy a criticar a la gente que ahora
tiene las puertas abiertas Pero al final
es cierto que cuando uno participa en
este tipo de actos sin poder hablar
sin poder criticar sin ni siquiera poder
cuestionar
uno es parte de una campaña que es más
grande que uno mismo
para promover el régimen sí a pesar de
estos cuestionamientos Los profesionales
del cine de todo el mundo no pudieron
resistirse a la llamada de los
petrodólares el mercado Saudita es muy
atractivo la población es joven rica y
está dispuesta a pagar más de 20 dólares
por entrada
[Música]
y este hombre está decidido a aprovechar
al máximo estas circunstancias
[Música]
distribuye la mayoría de las películas
del país en salas de cine nuevas y
monumentales quiere mostrarnos esta sala
y sus grandiosas columnatas en el
corazón de hielo
[Música]
sabe que aquí el potencial del Séptimo
arte es infinito
[Música]
hoy tenemos 500 pantallas en el país que
hemos construido en solo cuatro años y
podemos decir que Arabia Saudita
representa el 40 45% de la taquilla de
todo el medio oriente
El objetivo a la larga es tener 2000
pantallas
[Música]
por segunda ocasión el pasado diciembre
se organizó un Festival Internacional de
Cine en jedi
[Música]
en la alfombra roja lentejuelas vestidos
glamurosos y sonrisas faisal y su equipo
no esconden su alegría
[Aplausos]
ahora las posibilidades son infinitas
puede trabajar en su país para los
sauditas antes no podíamos hacer las
películas comerciales donde las
habríamos proyectado Así que hacíamos
películas viajábamos por todo el mundo
para proyectarlas en los mayores
festivales internacionales pero no
podíamos proyectarlas en Arabia Saudita
Ahora sí podemos junto a él Sharon Stone
Melanie Loren Jackie Chan Charlotte y
Antonio Banderas el Jurado del festival
estaba presidido por Oliver Stone
creo que aquellos que critican a Arabia
Saudita deberían visitar el país hay
mucho que ver
en el hotel donde se celebra el festival
le seguimos los pasos a Daniel sisquín
productor francés especializado en cine
árabe Hola cómo estás Y en este pequeño
mundo siempre hay un colega
me alegra verte
Te presento a Mohamed un amigo que
saludar dos películas una Indonesia y
una serie de Marvel Disney
sabes que esta noche presentamos una
película hunging Gardens
incluso tiene un pequeño detalle para el
organizador del festival Buenas tardes
mucho gusto Estoy buscando al Señor
abdulá tengo algo para él
esta caja de chocolates es lo mínimo
para alguien que puede abrirle tantas
puertas lo más importante es que la
reciba Pero él no está acá o sí
sí hay que venir obviamente hay que
venir pero es el mismo dilema de la
gente a la que le gusta el fútbol que no
va al Mundial de Qatar Por qué se
indignan hasta ahora
Busca financiamiento las producciones
europeas necesitan dinero y según él los
sauditas son interlocutores serios
Amantes del cine y a quienes les
interesa invertir inteligentemente las
condiciones económicas son las mismas
que con cualquier otro socio hay un
rendimiento de inversión Obviamente el
Espejismo del dinero fácil del mundo
árabe no existe pueden existir en la
facilidad del ser bien recibido Pero en
cuanto se va al grano de hacer una
película La relación con el cine es
económica
Francia tiene incluso su propio pabellón
en esta feria reservado a los
productores el país forma a jóvenes
cineastas sauditas y facilita los
encuentros challenge es agregado del
Consulado para él nada está prohibido en
el cine Francia debe acompañar a este
país que se abre a gran velocidad
el balance del país en materia de
Derechos Humanos etcétera Francia está
cómoda con esto
si me pregunta por el cine me quedo en
el tema del cine la oferta presentada
que también está en los cines de la
ciudad tiene censura cero
este festival es un paréntesis de
libertad en un país donde toda expresión
está supervisada el día de la apertura
los organizadores presentaron El capitán
azul de la marroquí mariam tusani
película que habla abiertamente de la
homosexualidad
proyectada una sola vez no será
distribuida comercialmente en el reino
en cuanto a las películas para el gran
público la censura o las prohibiciones
son frecuentes
algunos dibujos animados por ejemplo han
sido prohibidos porque muestran parejas
del mismo sexo o escenas de desnudos el
canal gubernamental alec Bari también
manifestó su preocupación por ciertos
fragmentos que fueron difuminados
durante su emisión alegando la
influencia subversiva de los valores
occidentales
sí podemos hacer un festival en el que
haya estrellas internacionales que
vengan vestidas como el festival de
cannes
en el que haya películas internacionales
que podrían proyectarse en cualquier
otro festival
la verdadera pregunta es si serán
proyectadas en Arabia
qué tan difundidas
creo que las películas con connotaciones
políticas nunca serán proyectadas en
Arabia habrá censura
no hay necesidad de censura la película
no se proyecta nadie la distribuye
el hombre clave del cine Saudita es el
abdula aleyab presidente de la comisión
de cine
para financiar el sector dispone de un
presupuesto casi ilimitado
es ingeniero y director premiado y no le
preocupan las críticas occidentales
ASUME un cine acorde con los valores
sauditas y rechaza cualquier acusación
de propaganda
siempre habrá prejuicios sobre Arabia
Saudita
antes nuestro país era acusado de no
tener una industria cinematográfica de
no apoyar a los cineastas y ahora
tenemos este apoyo tenemos esta
industria y nos acusan de utilizarla
para limpiar nuestra imagen eso Es
hipócrita tenemos derecho a contar
nuestras propias historias y hacerlo en
el cine una de las formas de arte más
bellas a Germán
desarrollar el cine no consiste solo en
mostrar una imagen menos polémica a
Occidente
Por cuánto tiempo podrán los sauditas
beneficiarse de los ingresos del
petróleo
el oro negro crea pocos empleos y
perpetúa las desigualdades los más ricos
no trabajan los demás sufren un alto
índice de desempleo
una economía Dual en un estado
omnipotente que el príncipe quiere
reformar
[Música]
Y eso significa formación significa
trabajar en el sector privado en vez en
el público como en Francia en los viejos
tiempos trabajar más para ganar más si
quieren mejorar su estatus
socioeconómico solo tienen que trabajar
más y no en el sector público sino más
bien en el privado
el reino Tiene un plan Saw division 2030
que está expuesto en todas partes junto
a los rostros del príncipe y del Rey
salman su padre
un presupuesto de un billón de dólares
para transformar la economía invertir en
turismo nuevas tecnologías y proyectos
gigantescos como neón
[Música]
parece salida de un tráiler de ciencia
ficción esta ciudad futurista está
siendo construida en medio del desierto
The Line la línea
un edificio de 170 kilómetros de largo y
500 metros de alto Con dudosas promesas
ecológicas Whitney Forest resaltings
[Música]
este proyecto verá el día en tan solo 7
años y el cine ya tiene su lugar en esta
ciudad algunos estudios y estos bungalos
en la arena el régimen quiere atraer a
este desierto a equipos de rodaje de
todo el mundo promete pagar el 40% del
presupuesto de cada rodaje sin impuestos
Neón será un reino dentro del reino con
sus propias leyes diferentes de las del
resto del país la operación de
comunicación está a cargo de consultores
extranjeros muy bien remunerados cuidado
hay un escalón
el australiano waynework está de paso
por el país y vino a presumir de los
equipos de última tecnología de neón
nuestra Villa de medios se extenderá a
lo largo de un millón de metros
cuadrados tendremos entre 45 y 50
estudios de cine estudios de videojuegos
y espacios de trabajo dedicados a
incubadoras de startups será el primer
centro integrado de del mundo
pero más allá de los anuncios es
imposible saber más
usted habla del estatus especial de neón
Qué significa eso
puedo hablar de eso
sí tendremos nuestras propias leyes
nuestras propias normas para poder
atraer a los mejores talentos a las
mejores empresas para empujar nuestra
ambición de crear un centro con una
verdadera potencia económica y social
los términos no son claros pero los
cálculos son sencillos conseguir que los
equipos de rodaje trabajen en Neón
significa inyectar millones de dólares
en la economía local
diversificarse también significa
fomentar el turismo
Bienvenidos a unla
[Música]
la frontera sur del Antiguo reino
navatero hace 2000 años
[Música]
ruta de los caravaneros que
transportaban sus especies al
Mediterráneo
[Música]
pocos viajeros extranjeros han podido
explorar estas montañas pero el país
otorga visas de turista desde 2019
de ecosistema
antes estas tumbas eran consideradas un
vestigio de la época de la ignorancia
antes de la llegada del islam ahora
cientos de guías locales que hablan
inglés han sido formados como mashael
alenzi ella ha estado aquí desde el
principio Hace 4 años
We have
some Mind we can go
[Música]
rdame antes de que el gobierno
invirtiera aquí el lugar estaba abierto
pero no había organización no había nada
no había guardias ni guías
estoy orgullosa porque soy de aquí nací
en alhuala recuerdo todos los sitios y
hoy es una chica de albola la que
realiza el recorrido
el objetivo es crear un millón de
empleos y recibir 100 millones de
visitantes de aquí a 2030
el estado planea utilizar el cine para
cambiar la imagen del país como con
estos turistas españoles mirar qué chulo
eh pero es una pasada eh súper guapo eh
la estrategia funciona estas tumbas se
parecen allí como
Indonesia es una pasada
Cómo ha conocido
pues me imagino que siempre hablan a la
Arabia Saudita es algo súper interesante
para mí cuando digo voy a Arabia saudí
me dicen para los audí pero no porque
bueno derechos humanos no la no sé qué
no sé cuánto Y yo que no porque no pasa
nada y he alucinado no tiene nada que
ver a lo que pone en internet todo lo
que sea
los sauditas comprendieron el poder que
tiene el cine y la imagen
Así que llamaron a un profesional
un estadounidense de Texas es el
encargado del alojamiento en alumnos
[Música]
como pueden ver todo es nuevo nos
aseguramos de cuidarlo y estamos en un
hermoso paisaje
nos llevó a conocer la film residence un
hotel especialmente diseñado para alojar
equipos de rodaje y aquí cada vez llegan
más solicitudes estamos en la fase uno
con 150 habitaciones en la fase 2
construiremos otras 150 Así que
tendremos 300 en total estamos a 20
minutos del increíble paisaje natural de
alula y también estamos construyendo dos
estudios permanentes a 20 minutos al sur
de donde estamos aquí se han hospedado
los técnicos de varias superproducciones
estadounidenses y del primer
largometraje Saudita rodado en este
lugar
el cine impulsa el turismo para
desarrollar las infraestructuras y
promocionar el destino
entre más gente vea en la pantalla esos
paisajes naturales únicos más ganas
tendrán de venir a verlos en la vida
real
[Aplausos]
[Música]
volvemos a la sala de cine de jeda al
final de la primera función de sus vidas
hablamos con las tres jóvenes salgua
safiya y rim
las conmovió la historia de una
bailarina surcoreana con un futuro
trágico todavía tengo lágrimas en los
ojos
Es una muy buena película denuncia
muchas cosas
y es la primera vez que veo una película
así normalmente veo películas de acción
o comedias me gustó mucho
[Música]
una apertura controlada una economía
diversificada Libertad para crear sin
criticar Este es el proyecto de sociedad
que el príncipe heredero ha impuesto a
la fuerza Pero cuánto durarán estas
nuevas posibilidades
[Música]
en algún momento la gente desarrolla el
concepto de derecho de lo que tiene lo
que acabamos de adquirir no es un
privilegio es un derecho es parte de la
vida cotidiana pero hemos visto
sociedades que han ido en dirección
completamente opuesta
han empleado mucha violencia y represión
Y eso está por verse
pero si me preguntan ahora a corto plazo
si hay algún cambio reforma que puedan
ser considerados Yo diría que sí
es posible porque depende de una sola
persona
[Música]
frágil o permanente la apertura de los
cines es un escaparate de la Arabia
Saudita contemporánea
el futuro nos mostrará lo que la
juventud del país hará con esta ventana
abierta al mundo y si provocará otros
cambios en el país
[Música]